marca vacca volevo fare una intro
decenza cronache di un raffreddore
giorno 1
parlo con nyon ha un tappetino del cane
è ancora integro ciò vuol dire che o non
doveva fare la pipì o l'ha fatta dove
non doveva l'ha fatta dove non doveva
l'ha fatta dove non doveva
[Musica]
pp ecco ecco la eccola eccola eccola
bravo bravo
bologna bisogna solo aiutarlo a fare
centro
fai centro di più che dice ciao parenti
lei macina adesso c'è il raffreddore
salutare parente due parenti dopo
giornata lavorativa in corso devo
registrare sei video perché prima di
partire per le vacanze come sempre
tramite video da parte perché se non lo
faccio smettiamo il cavo mi serve essere
distruggere summit con più il computer e
mio puoi uscire un secondo per corte di
niente meno male che ho lanciato le
cuffie che ormai sono abituati via
gliene frega niente devo registrare sei
video perché devo andare summit
ma cosa stai facendo ma esce e ci devo
ma cane cane puoi uscire per cortesia
dal mio studio devo registrare 8 video
per le vacanze di natale se non posso
andare a casa
non possiamo andare a casa se non
registro quello grazie è arrivata alla
mamma e quindi mi ha accorciato queste
cose che sono dei cuoricini per che
simboleggiano il suo amore per me però
mamma grazie ha detto per me non per te
quella roba che vede tempo un poco
uniforme hogwarts e la base di hogwarts
sto facendo sta qua per fare dovrebbe
venire così io ho fatto solo sto pezzo
qua sua in basso ci metterò tipo penso
che la mia vita intera non basti però
però contento di averci provato
la regia mamma la mia te lo attacca 12
12 12 vai mai mai mai a niente cenacoli
swift con gli slip ma esattamente cos'è
che c'è io ti giuro che non ti capisco
vuoi da mangiare non te lo posso dare
vuole giocare vuole giocare ma salti
chilometrica genti e dovremmo fare delle
cose noi importanti non puoi fare quello
che vuoi del no soffermerò con la forza
del pensiero
fermati bravo visto come funziona la
portare pensieri di paglia perché da me
cosa fai spiegami pisacane qui o il
cordino della videocamera sky contro i
cordini e scemo
la devi smettere i cordini non te li
puoi mordere tutti
il core o dei mollarlo non è capito o
smettila
il video di oggi consiste nel fare
l'albero di natale no visto che no no no
no no visto che l'albero di natale
ancora non l'ho fatto vorrei fare la
dolina tale igoogle plaid esposito
[Musica]
ponzi o non come justin bieber si sa è
una tigre è nativo e tigre si batte
google basta del partito ma che botte ai
questioni di nuovo cosa ti devi muovere
cosa ti devi bambaci bravo e siamo
quindi giunti ad un nuovissimo episodio
di cache accor cane perché la cacca coi
cani non si fa mai da soli grazie some
che mi accompagni nei momenti migliori
della mia vita ti sono debitore di
questo vuole il mio telefono perché
ovviamente non mi ricordo ultima volta
che l'ho pagato da solo samp lascia
stare le ciabatte lasciata sun non sanno
e non hai capito niente vieni qua sto
pagando non posso alzarmi vieni qua
questa è la spalla di final fantasy
versione bar da allora prima regola
prima regola non avere un cane ma
figurati se riesce fattore di stress che
mi ha dato il piedistallo sbagliato
allora può anche ai ragazzi la prima
parte è fatta incredibile ci siamo
riusciti apro io che in qualche io e
riprendi io apro come si dice i rami che
bello che c'è il natale dei sofferti di
lì sì direi che
cosa ci mette veramente tanto abbiamo
fatto un cambio perché mi sono reso
conto che io non sono proprio ferrato in
estensione di rami di alberi finti quel
non me ne intendo di mia mamma davvero
si è infatti mi sa che ho preso da terra
no no
some perché ti devi mangiare così
dell'albero a natale regala anche tu dei
cuccioli di barboncino le tue amiche a
natale esorcizza anche tutto il cane
vai su www.sky.it o ci sono anche tu
come ho fatto io
[Musica]
braga abbiamo finito
abbiamo costruito una barriera
artificiale per il cane che ha
funzionato dai ok abort mission schifo
smettila di mangiare i pezzi dell'albero
bene abbiamo finito a prendere risultato
finale
ecco a posto
no
[Musica]
se questa mattina della morte
siamo passati allo sbrogliato delle luci
ammasso di voci bravo ma perfetto e
adesso mettiamo le luci abbiamo trovato
la soluzione la barriera anti cane ce
l'abbiamo fatta
sì ecco non ha scherzato qui vedete
lorenzo completamente distrutto per aver
fatto l'albero questo è l'albero
questo è il lavoro che ha fatto lorenzo
e adesso proviamo ad accenderlo
ovviamente la testa nella mia tasca
cerca tutto nelle tasche incanalare bene
andiamo al momento della cessione se
tutto va bene sarà un buon natale questa
che si difesa sono stato un delitto
mamma mia il mio presto e un albero di
natale
quello che mi hai fatto guarda che però
mette poi a caso sul viola è bellissimo
ma che gli frega a lui che stamani ha
rispettato loro è fighissimo
beh per essere un albero di natale
cinese non è male e poi sa cosa sia la
neve da mettere sotto finta è quella che
è niente commenta a sotto l'albero dove
lo sai che se lo metti per terra due
minuti e piede pisciato qualcosa ha
rotto le balle per tutto il lavoro
adesso che abbiamo finito si
addormentare coperta di neve tutti ci
vediamo ad un prossimo episodio di
natale di ci chiamiamo
duemila parisi natale bocca ci vediamo
al presidente di natale col cane questo
è tutto
spero che gli sia piaciuto il papa per
aver comprato l'albero cinese
ringrazio i cinesi per aver fatto
l'albero in rialzo il cane per aver
contribuito a distruggerci l'albero che
abbiamo fatto e la mamma che ha messo a
posto
durante tutto il vicinato che faccio
iscrivetevi mi raccomando dobbiamo
arrivare a 5 milioni prima di sabato
perché se arriviamo a 5 milioni prima di
sabato sabato esce o speciale cipro
iscritti
iscrivetevi fate scrivere anche i vostri
amici i vostri cani gatti create di un
account google secondario fate descrive
anche a penale perché entro sabato
avete lo speciale beh ragazzi
[Musica]